these two quadrilaterals quadratic e f g
h and a b c d these are similar if
there's some combination of translations
rotations reflections and dilations i
can make them sit on top of each other
and similarity allows us to use
dilations which essentially means scale
up one of the figures up or down if
we're talking about congruence then we
wouldn't be scaling the figures up or
down we would only be translating
rotating and reflecting but let's see if
we can do it so let's first translate it
let's first translate this figure
so let's make that point on top of that
point and now let's
rotate it
and we're going to rotate it around
point e right over here
so i get right over there so i got two
of the sides to kind of match up but now
let me dilate it down let me scale it
down and so this is let me put it on
where i want to what i want to not
change and then let me see if i can
scale
this
down and i was able to so through just
purely translations rotations i didn't
even have to use the reflections
translations rotations and dilations i
was able to make these sit on top of
each other so these two figures these
two figures are similar so yes the
rectangles are similar let's do one more
of these
so
these two triangles and just eyeballing
it this one looks kind of taller than
this one does right over here so they
don't feel similar but let me at least
let me at least try
so let me translate maybe make this
point
point c might correspond to point f
although it already looks pretty clear
that it won't but now let me
dilate it let me
i'll keep that point where it is and let
me try to scale this up
and then we see pretty clearly we made
segment
cb sit on top of or after scaling it up
sit on top of segment f e but then
everything else is not matching up point
d is in a very different place than
where point a is once i try to scale
things up a little bit so these two
triangles are clearly clearly not
similar